beyond the holocaust
the united states has concluded that
genocide was committed seven times
today marks the eighth
as i have determined that members of the
burmese military committed genocide and
crimes against humanity against rohingya
the attack against rohingya was
widespread and systematic
which is crucial for reaching a
determination of crimes against humanity
the evidence also points to a clear
intent behind these mass atrocities the
intent to destroy rohingya in whole or
in part
that intent has been corroborated by the
accounts of soldiers who took part in
the operation and later defected
such as one who said he was told by his
commanding officer to and i quote
shoot at every site of a person end
quote
burn villages
rape and kill women
orders that he and his unit carried out
since the coup
we've seen the burmese military use many
of the same tactics
only now
the military is targeting anyone it sees
as opposing or undermining its
repressive rule
since seizing power the military's
killed more than 1 670 men women and
children
and unjustly detained at least 12 800
more in abysmal conditions
we're providing a wide range of support
including information
resources
and today i can announce that we're also
contributing nearly a million dollars in
additional funding
we've also shared information with the
gambia in connection with the case it's
filed against burma under the genocide
convention at the international court of
justice for the atrocities committed
against rohingya